request
s
[Music]
hello hello everyone thank you for the
organizer for inviting me
so this is Joint work with the my
student normally sitting there
you know if anyone doesn't know him and
Jadu is not seeking you good
so
let's start with the basic let's start
with the what Randomness is okay we all
know but still
computer science for algorithms
either we don't have them without
Randomness or way more efficient with
randomness and definitely for
cryptography
and I'm going to focus on cryptography
okay
the use of Randomness so not speaking
generally I'm going to see something
specific but let's start
so why are known as important
photography for many reasons but maybe
the the key example is one thing pad
so I want to encrypt the string so I
simply EXO it with a random string which
is the key and to the clip you
accelerate again with the key and you
get back
so this is great encryption schemes like
you get an unbounded
but the problem is that the key is very
long right as long as the message and
this is machine on that case not in deep
type of Channel 448 but it's people for
49 actually so that this is inherent
you're gonna do better than that
so what do we do we use pseudo
randomness
what is
so uh actually a computational analog of
Randomness naturally when I speak on
Randomness and think about uniform
string okay uniform means okay
a sample from one distribution
basically the same like probability
output one when you get the message from
the other decision
good so Sudanese
is important because you can generate it
you can generate using efficient
computable function which you call it
pseudorado generator
which is an algorithm that gets you know
a few truly random bit and I'll put many
pseudo-anomics
so the output of a uniform short string
and the output way more bits than the
input
n is efficient okay so this is
computation secure encryption for
instance because you can now Echo the
message with the output of the Sudan
United
and now you use the key which is key
okay can be my smartphone
good
and
constructing prgs from basic assumption
is challenging it's not the topic of
this talk I want to relate to it
slightly it's not completely talk but
this is like just keep in mind
okay so we start to learn this let's go
zoom out let's talk about entropy
so entropy this formulation is measure
the randomness of a string if a string
is truly or random variable it's true
uniform then the entropy should be
maximized if it's content constant the
entropy should be zero and entropy the
entropy function give you everything in
between
an example if it's an N bit string the
Enterprise and if it's somewhat
Randomness then the entropy is some
something between zero in it okay
so entropy this it seems like rather
arbitrary formulation actually under
some assumption a a assumption it's the
only formulation but to see that for
instance this is the minimal description
left for X if you want to compress X you
can compress it to the entropy to
address it in a few slides
but it also the number of random bits
uniforms random bit required example X
and computer scientists it's also what
the number of random bit can be
extracted to Max okay so and to really
capture something really
basic fundamental about this position
does the other version of entropy most
notably mean entropy which is the worst
case version million two people on the
variable it's the log wonderful the
probability of the most likely
good so like for Randomness with pseudo
Randomness for entropy with
pseudoentropy absolutely for entropy
with many analogs okay this is a big
part of this talk but let's start with
the first one which is pseudo entropy
back in 89
says the following a random variable is
pseudo entropy
please okay if there is a different
unavailable Y which is true Shannon
entropy the formulas I gave before is
What's called the Channel
entropy is at least a and is
computationally distinguishable from X
okay
why is it important there's many
variants to the minerals metrics we're
going to be but why is it important why
is it going to be is important why
computational analogs of entropy are
important the reason is that we
understand information theoretically
very well maybe not us
specifically but people in the same
information to a few people way better
than we understand complete computation
right
allows to do the following we take a
result that someone proved rather easily
on the information theoretic regime and
then use exactly the same tool on
different unavariables
and claim for the security by the fact
that if it works from the real entropy
measure it should work also when the
computer computation analog and
otherwise you can break the analog okay
otherwise you can break you you you you
prove that something that you fought is
is
okay this is a great Paradigm very
useful Paradigm all over the
cryptography I guess also over
complexity as well
so that's an example I want to go from
pseudo entropy so do Randomness whatever
source
so we know the different variable is a
lot of entropy absolutely cheating if
you development entropy and you apply
random random Kitty and again you needed
to see it but let's ignore that but for
the sake of the presentation then you
can extract something which is basically
what you said the number of the number
of unability tests the entropy so if it
turns into PK you can extract K random
numbers
so now
so now on if you have a different Nano
variable of pseudo entropies is K okay
is entropy might be very low but it's
pseudo-entropies okay and then you can
apply the same extractor as long as it
is efficient extractor when you argue
that his output with computation
distinguishable from uniform why is that
because if you could distinguish you
could break the pseudoentropy of the
original
this may be the most basic
example how to exploit computational
analogs of it very simple
okay let's see another analog of entropy
to be which is next blocks slightly more
complicated
it says the following this is the joint
work with Omer and vadan
from 13 years already
so a random variable we can figure
[Music]
this next block pseudoentropy
actually if there is a different
variable Y which is again y one to y n
such as the following words
first
given any prefix of X you cannot
distinguish between the next bit of x
form
the beta the if bit of one
okay it's adjointed distributed why is
jointed distributed indexed and why it
doesn't make sense
again you cannot distinguish given any
prefix you cannot tell whether the next
bit you're getting from X or for y
and
the if you sum up the entropy of Y given
the prefixes then the sum of the entropy
is K
okay the easiest way to to figure out
what it means that it's General it's a
okay so x i is somewhat how to predict
even x given the prefix why it is how to
predict as y i is how to predict so it
measure done predictability of the
source okay
and those I guess those of you are
familiar with Yahoo and predictability
and predictability says that no
efficient algorithm can predict the next
bit given the the the the the the
history better than guessing this is a
quantitative variant of it say well
maybe you can
but not too good
entropy right because I'm guessing this
yeah if you think it's made to configure
so
um so we say well you can predict maybe
some of the bits are very easy to
predict
but overall you cannot predict to wear
what is not well not too well then k
okay
and uh it's used to construct actually
the best construction I would like to
say the backstrom's actually one
function of fluid for one function but
the recent result of norm and Rafael
improve it by Logan beats so no it's not
the best construction it's still the
best construction I guess
okay and
Define for arbitrary block lens but I
want to focus on one big block
Okay so we've seen two computational
analog centerpiece they are way more so
this is the general Paradigm okay
identify use the property of
distribution of I entropy
next week and unpredictability and
compressibility whatever and then Define
computation analog only of this property
okay
and then use tool that works for this
property and apply them on the analogs
okay so his example pseudo Randomness
pseudoentropy unpredictability next book
is going to be we're going to introduce
to our next slide
actually before that all this noise
encaps are what's called an
indistinguishability of distributions
that I don't know it's like inaccessible
until it captures like something very
different that I entropy is associative
we would say to construct status
just the curious I live in question so
the information to edit settings the
meeting is very robust and the sense
that all these Notions are equivalent
exactly in the computer in the usual
computational setting they're all kind
of separate exactly so now and now what
happens in between say if we have very
weak computational models
parties so for your first part of the
answer the good answer a full question a
good answer for example I don't know
the second questions those who are
interested you know who to work with
so but this is a good question why do we
need many other ones I mean for entropy
we have only one we should plan to pay
give them all why do you need many other
books so I thought of the following
example it's a bit stupid okay if you
have an elephant an elephant is both
huge and gray okay
giraffe is also used but it's not great
okay but something if you only want to
exploit the huginess of an elephant then
it's also applied to giraffe but if you
want to destroy the fact that an
elephant this guy then it doesn't like
it
have many properties
you know like you you take one of the
properties and you find analog from that
and then whatever only all the the tools
that only require this property works
for your analog other tools are not
going to work because you know giraffe
is not right okay
this is why we need many analogs okay a
difference okay
yeah
um
so what is compression the compression
skin is a pair of algorithm encoding and
coding algorithm such if you encode and
then the code you get the same button
okay
all right and the goal is to compress
the goal is that you find the encoding
such as if you sample from the
distribution you get the average sort of
self
accomplish
and Shannon showed
beautiful result that
compression is really the size of
depression is captured by the entry up
to one bit okay you can compress the
random variable exactly two is going to
be up to one bit
at least if I restrict myself to what
clip prefix encoding which means one
encoding is not a prefix on a different
port encoding which is important
otherwise when you actually use it in
practice when you send many symbols you
cannot decode okay so if you think about
prefix code which is the for this code
the the compression rate is exactly then
okay up to one bit
so Yahoo box in 82 in paper which I
think the same paper would
would one more interpretation and
whatever into one section one section
[Music]
um
he gives the equivalent of
conversational and distinguishability
does
pretty much everything yeah
most of the paper he's talking about the
effect of entropy yeah so this is
about it so right one or two section go
and get about till now probably in 50
years people will start caring about the
other two sections so if you want to
find a result that you put in the 15
years good
so we've got a fat event
so the following well I don't care why
call effective I don't care that you can
compress the distribution to very few
bits the question can you do it
efficiently okay you said the effective
entropy of X is the again the minimal
the encoding lens
but you restrict yourself to polynomial
time encoding and decoding
a note by the way that even if the
distribution is computable for every X
you can say is probability compressing
might be difficult if the domain is
large because asthma encoding for
instance
is polynomial in the size of the domain
so the domain is exponential even though
you can compute the probability it might
be difficult to cope with
efficient teacher
good
so what is income possibility it's the
opposite X is K incompressible if no
efficient algorithm can compress it to
less than kbps
very natural definition okay
and it's interesting if
the entropy is smaller if we have a gap
computational entropy are only
interesting if the entropy in the analog
is larger than the real entropy if it's
the same like the real end if like the
real entropy worth nothing I mean you're
not going to get anything so it's
interesting if the K is like 100 bits
incompressible but it's really entropy
is five okay oh it's a 99
and
this nose is not well understood so you
know like why it's not aggressive dude
for instance we don't know even what
simple manipulate
to this knows if you take parallel
instances like in only any other notion
of a analog friendly when you take a
parallel repetition
multiplies if we don't know that okay
you also don't know the relation to
other computational Notions entropy so
typically we have good good
understanding
what comes what like whether one analog
implies the other when or not okay here
we didn't one exception
back in all three show The Following you
can extract K minus Omega FL Logan bits
of pseudo and a bit
but distribution not with K
impossibility strong invariance of
compressibility
worst case variants you can think about
this mean entropy okay
very beautiful result very beautiful
elegant proof the the construction is
very simple we just apply reconstructive
extractor on the source you apply the
reconstructive so if someone distinguish
it from uniform then because the exacto
is Recon reconstructive you can get back
the source so you compress okay those of
you know what reconstructed
forget about it so it was used actually
it took 70 years for this order to be
used and and it was using construction
PRD from harness in a different result
so this is great but I'm claiming that
it's not really the right result okay in
several senses first
foreign
but thirdly it doesn't say much about
that thing about the stocks itself it's
a river Source it's incompressible you
do something to eat then you have a
something random but it doesn't say
enough about what
if you are incompressible what does it
mean about you can you relate it
directly something only you can only
apply something then say something about
it so it's very nice but it still
there's a missing of understanding yeah
compressibility gives you extraction I
mean it seems like it's connected to
General entropy there's no there's no
incapable possibility I mean in the ah
if you do before
right because that's why that notion is
mean basically
so it's not the incompressibility so but
but can you hope to extract from
compressibility you don't right no no
you cannot accept because nothing means
it's not the worst case you cannot do
that so okay
still you know
it may depends that when you do
repetition then you can accept the
problem there's a new repetition we
don't know that it works
again
elephant elephants
okay so it gives the world is probably
the student before this is that so we
have this may be the basically
basic notion of computational analog of
entropy the pseudoentropy next week
incompressibility what is the relation
so first
these two equivalent one function what
do I mean by that I mean that if you
have non-trivial pseudo entropy the
sooner entropy is noticeably larger than
the real entropy then it implies when a
function and one a function also
suffices by using constantly so
different generator to construct that
same for next box would entropy but not
one composibility we didn't know that
and pseudoentropy implies next to the
entropy this is a easy to show
the definition and it implies
compatibility also because if you can
compress you basically the proof that
how to distinguish a entropy
distribution
this is going to show that it's not
the right way to go you cannot do that
or if the source is next that way is
very large but it's going to be very
small by the way I'm doing with time
with all these stupid jokes I think that
yes waste all my time
left
sorry okay no more jokes so so uh
so so they'll say okay so just write it
down yeah anyway
so it's easy to see the next box you
don't it does not apply to bits and huge
gaps uh also it doesn't imply a
incompressibility let me write this
example G
think about
an X
the pseudo entropy is nothing it's like
X because you see X okay also it's very
easy to compress it because you compress
X but the next words you don't repeat if
you look it from left to right it adds a
lot of next bit so don't be coming from
X
there's vocal separation between
actually I think did it uh between the
composibility and sudo entropy but it
doesn't there's a source that has a lot
is incompressible but it's not a it's
going to be only but again only if you
if you are working separation
but this was the missing link I mean we
didn't know whether something which is
compressible has a lot of next students
basically okay so that's one question
from the result
about this this
error I mean this thing when you think
about the first time say clearly
incompressibility implies one function
but if there's no one a function you can
compress so it's not actually so
so
that's one note we only care about
sample distributions which you can
simply using a efficient algorithm so if
one function do not exist then you know
that you can randomly you can randomly
invert any any function okay then
you say is the way to compress you get a
distribution sample distribution you
invert it and then you output the
pre-image right
is shorter than the output maybe to
sample distribution you need a very long
primitive so you can try to do
pre-sampling Etc but you don't get the
right what you like okay maybe you can
do it directly but it's not naive yeah
using free sampling subsampling no like
hashing that's yeah something yeah I
guess but you know that's exactly what
you like
um prefix print
as well
uh because they're asking if you're not
going to available
well you can just if that that others
you can just give the whole string no
sense so if you do action
so it's not clear how do you decode
because to decode you need the perimeter
dashing but if you try to invert it you
might be AFL let's take it offline but
okay it's it's not clear that it's
working I mean it seems plausible but
it's not revealed that's what I have to
say I mean the fact that Russell solve
it four days ago doesn't mean it
is not Dimension it's not
so first what is the relation between
possibility to other computational and
entropy
you don't know any particular does not
even compensability like cryptography
is
a very simple proof which is tied to the
non-eroes
oh so it's a result the following
impossibility actually implies
an exactly organization if x is k
incompressible then it has next bit
Sudan to be K minus two we're losing two
bits okay
one bit is unavoidable because it might
be the even that a source is as a
a is a k a in the information literatic
settings it might be the one bit Gap
okay okay you can compress to something
you have to compress you have to spend
one bit more okay this is Channel
second bit we don't know we spend time
we didn't manage to get rid of the
second
um a few colors so if x is sampling with
non-trivial uh incompressibility then
namely it's go is greater by two bits
plus this entropy then it implies one
function
and second thing means if there is if no
one function n is every sample but X can
be efficient complex to its entropy plus
two bits
again no error or nothing
a
okay so what is the proof ID
the good idea is if a source you know
counterpositive if x doesn't get a lot
of students P we want to compress
so think we have a source X
you have a source X
foreign
you know only is K minus two bits are
unpredictable if you go from left to
right but all of these are predictable
it's very easy to predict okay they're
all zeros
so definitely you can compress okay
because simply
output the last case
so if like it doesn't have a lot of next
between two people because of trivial
reasons then the frequent compress
it becomes older if you know like
some beats are hard to predict some are
not how to predict but you don't know
where
you become much harder
if you know this bit is somewhat
predicted it feels bit somewhat ultimate
everything sum up to K or even all bits
are some slightly out of the mix how can
you compress
okay
so basically this is our answer and yeah
let's go to the result so actually the
result
the proof simply does you have to hide
down the preliminaries and you have
nothing to do else I mean so nothing
else to do it's like I mean technically
it's the simplest paper I've ever wrote
I mean it took us a time we tried to We
Invented some of the tools that people
knew 40 years ago actually one of Jordan
10 years ago like our import arithmetic
encoding but after you you try to come
up you find out that someone already did
it better than you and just you plug
everything together and you get you
better okay really it's one of these
cases that
you're lucky everything is ready you
just need to let them know
okay so what do you know so every 15
minutes more we said
if I call correctly
okay
fit me yes so let me slightly about
compressions keep slightly more details
that's definition I'm going to speak
about K in their words
then I'm going to speak about
compressing ground distribution measure
using calendar version
and then I'm going to cite beautiful
results by salil and calling from 10
years ago that to show the taxi next
block through the entropy is equivalent
what's called krldness
foreign
and knowing what you finish writing them
all the the proofs will go pop up
good so we focus on non-uniform case for
now distinguishing a polycytes
simplifies our life
so again we know what the comparison is
a scheme for for for a distribution a
prefix key it means that
the encoding of one element is not a
prefix of coding a different element
and we have also what's called three
point wise scheme which means that the
encryption side of every element is at
most one over logged one over log the
log of one over the probability plus C
okay this is like 0.5 promise guarantee
about encryption the the encoding
and it's immediate that if you ever see
a c Point wise scheme then the
compressing is just the the entropy Plus
is one point wise you only spend at most
one bit more than one over a log over
one over the probability is a prefect
free which is great but it's inefficient
again running time depends on the
support
and we want to speak about arithmetic
encoding which is only two wise
point-wise this is why you pay the two
but in our setting is efficient even
though the the the the the support is
the exponential you know
I don't know actually Norm you know
anyone
their point was I promise I'm not sure I
don't know
they're competitive with the finance
they don't have a distribution right
it's a
yes
okay The Virgins so okay The Virgins
remember what entropies can Divergence
is the
like a complicated knowledge of
information which is actually sort of a
major of a distance between a
distributions is defined like that it is
a you take the the expectation Goods but
to the left hand side of a log the the
ratio of the mobility
that's a formula I mean don't they don't
don't stare into it too much but the way
you should express it and going to
justify it next slide is the surprise
when you expect to get a sample from y
but you're actually going to get a
simple format the amount of supplies
okay
and yeah
so here's a nice fact
let encoding it's up some encoding
scheme which is C Point wise for y
okay
so again you develop encoding scheme for
Y which is great it's C Point wise
but then you use it with x how good is
that coding okay you develop it for X
why but you use it for x
so very nice result information if you
will say well you achieve that which
this is what happened if we develop and
call this thing for x
plus the penalty which is the valid
entropy between X and Y okay this is the
only property we need for kid diversity
for this stock right one then you encode
distribution you pay this packet
okay
foreign
but given this
algorithm you can define a very long
distribution so first you feed him to
the empty string it gives you the
distribution of the first bit then you
take the first bit it's been sampled you
feed again you get the distribution for
the second bit you sample a columnistic
distribution second bit you feed it
again now with two bits give you
distribution for the fair bit and so on
you can continue what you like and
Define so estimate and Define the
distribution
if no poly size
for every poly size estimator the candle
version is when X and Y E this
distribution is at least okay so you're
going in life now is defined the
estimator such that mimic
X okay it's similar to X and you have to
you have to do it using estimator
and Kayla RNs mean that you cannot do
that
for any efficient estimator the K
Divergence between X and this
distribution is at least
y one three y i minus one is a number
between zero and one no it is a number
but every time you take it you take a
simple every time you take a sentence so
it gives you a number you take a sample
this is the first bit and then you've
got your number no this is a bit you
take the first bit the it's a bit you
give the first bit to e it gives you a
second number between zero one extent
but secondly now we have two bits you
feed them e you get the number two zero
one you sample accordingly you just
perfect and now we're thinking of the uh
meal plan algorithm yeah yeah you can if
e is
so what does superscript B stand for I
don't know so what is when you say y1
sub P yeah
so so this is it okay
these are the real the the ones inside
of the real coins or the these are the
points according to it so again this is
a random process I take y the wave
sample y one p i feed the E with the
empty string you give me 0.4 a simple a
bit
0.401.
it's a distribution over distributions
to do with the actual
output why do you call it in online
because the way you use it the the
estimate only give you zoom between zero
one so the way you generate is in online
you generate the first bit you feed them
you generate a second bit you feed in a
thousand but the way it's adapted to
Earth it's nothing like support but the
goal you you're going in life you'll
find the best is more
seem to finish things good right
so when you
get out the versions of that you're like
doing this bit by bit I can do by using
cane yeah you know I can do that you can
change it yeah okay so
yeah but you never you don't like use
the Y's you you you see it
so beautiful beautiful results
from 11 years ago says the following
actually care Agnes K minus
is equivalent next bit to the entropic
this equivalent okay
okay it's not so this seems very strange
notation but this notion equivalent a
random variable have K minus is entropy
if and only if is next between
can you give us some reduction
[Music]
random
then the ones I if so it should this be
the result
easy to do yeah it is so
um
it's not clear because if it's
what do you do with getting the
buildings I mean I mean it's going to be
huge even though this looks wonderful
right right
here so it's going to be oh I need to
think it depends nothing to do today
okay
why do you do that because I'm going to
use it to show that in possibilities
like next week so actually I'm going to
use this notes I'm going to use I say
I'm going to use it if next week
is
compressible okay then I can find out an
estimator so so we're confused I want to
show that Instagram development it
doesn't have a look
then I'm going to use this result to
show that why it is a small character
Divergence and then I'm going to to use
it to compress X
okay so to be the one side yeah so I
mean I wouldn't know how to do it but it
will be that surprised because this kale
hardness definition really talks about
like trying to predict the next thing
which is also what the next week to
learn to be directly tells you like if I
knew all the previous leads how hard it
would be to uh sort of how much how much
entropy or how hard the next one whereas
this is also sort of the game that you
play in in like
I know should we really be like yes
because how do you move from afterward
for prediction to
um
no so no if you don't have Netflix you
don't want to be it's made for everyone
for everyone You can predict I would do
there's many different wives nonsense
how do you use that to come up with one
distribution that achieves more care
level this is one started okay forever
generally there's many I didn't say that
yeah
the last situation then maybe like the
dangers of yourselves yeah good so let
me just
the thing so I say that if there's next
estimation then you can put less namely
if
if this does not hold
okay it doesn't develop the next bits of
entropy therefore by by selling and and
calling it doesn't add or to kill
otherness then you can compress okay
this is what we want to do because we
want to say well incompressibility
implies next block pseudoentropy so we
do the counter where counterpositive it
doesn't develop it doesn't have a lot of
career otherness I can complex this is
going to be contradiction
so given the estimator again it doesn't
have a lot of care and that's the essay
estimator I'm going to compress X using
compression scheme for y e what's great
about y e because it's a point wise I
can really compress it okay using what
using something
so I can really compress this okay why
you can compressor is one of these
distribution because it's generated
online main level adaptive manual
whatever you want to call it I can
really compress it to not with entropy
with entropy plus two okay
but how much I'm going to pay
for using for s
a compressing theme for y a how much
exactly
exactly compressing whole distribution
so I'm going to pay this quantity
I'm going to create this quantity
but if this content is small
I'm not going to pay much and this is
all proof
okay again
if Source doesn't allow a lot if I want
to prove the compressibility imply next
bits or not they say well it doesn't the
next bit we're going to be it's more
therefore best allele is kale evidence
oh what this means this one e
such that this this value is small this
one is this one I'm taking this e I'm
building a compressing scheme for the
distribution y this is easy because he
is efficient in y is building online
fashion
and now we're going to apply this
compressor for this for X not for y e
I'm going to pay how much you're going
to pay this quantity but this quantity
is more definitely this is the proof
I just realized if I asked a question I
wouldn't be able to talk
[Laughter]
okay so
um
um okay so basically okay assume X is no
Cayman students
there's an estimator with a scale
Divergent between X and Y E is small
dilemma which is because this 2.1
compression for y e which is just oh
it's already people know to do it this
is what arithmetic encoding
and by compressing more distribution the
encoding level of n is that's h of X
plus two plus Decay the versions
I said we did nothing but that's plugged
three results together
[Music]
this arithmetic encoding I spend a lot
of time in the flight uh doing these
pictures but
you know
too bad for you okay
uh when you want to do uniform
compressing it's like more challenging
but skip it so okay so just let me end
so open question first can you get rid
of the two bits Gap that you see two to
one bit
you know
and second question you know there's
totally no implication increased results
okay we thought we're going to have but
till now we found no but you know for
weakness Zone and Saltillo and Barack it
took them 17 years to find application
so you know take your time
you're 60 more years to do that and
thank you
[Applause]
I just compressed by inverting it uh
yeah
you just want to go for people
possibilities
I just wanted to do that it replies when
it functions then type one function yeah
you can just do it and then
it's going to be ill but yeah
Maybe
so
um
30 minutes